[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the events of the night of
october 31st
1981 the attack on godric's hollow it
was the night that lord voldemort
in an effort to stop the fabled prophecy
from coming true travelled to the humble
home of the potters
with one goal in mind kill the boy it
all started in the year 1980 when sipple
trelawny at a job interview for a
position at hogwarts
had a vision of the prophecy in
hogsmeade pub the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord approaches
born to those who have thrice to fight
him born as the seventh month dies
and the dark lord will mark him as his
equal but he will have power the dark
lord
knows not and either must die at the end
of the other
for neither can live while the other
survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord
will be born as the seventh month dies
snape
who served voldemort at the time
overheard the whole thing
and informed him of what he had heard
from there it was just a matter of
determining who this boy was
through the process of elimination it
came down to two boys
harry potter or neville longbottom
however
voldemort ended up choosing the potters
in an effort to protect their boy from
voldemort the potters went into hiding
and extreme security measures were put
into place not only were they protected
by the fidelious charm
but they also had the order of the
phoenix backing them
the fidelius charm is an incredibly
powerful piece of magic that conceals a
secret
inside of a chosen secret keeper's soul
and
in this instance the secret was the
potter's location the only hole in their
plan
was the man that they had chosen as
secret keeper peter pettigrew
a sniveling excuse for a man pettigrew
changed sides and gave up the location
of the potters to voldemort
leaving them wide open to his attack
when the time came for voldemort to
strike
he approached the potter's humble home
in the night and what started off as
just another unassuming october day
eventually became a day that would
change the course of history
though voldemort was a murderous man he
did not go to the potter's home to kill
harry's parents
he only wanted to kill harry the boy
that threatened his regime
though they did sometimes medal in his
affairs james and lily potter were not a
threat to voldemort
they were however in the way serving as
obstacles that prevented him from
killing harry
when he entered their home james potter
was the first to get in his way
the first line of defense protecting
lily and harry however
james had one very big problem he didn't
have his wand on him
the potters were caught completely off
guard because they never suspected
that their location would be revealed
and that they would be betrayed by their
secret keeper
because he didn't have his wand he was
no match for voldemort
though i suspect that even with it
voldemort would have made quick work of
him
james was a talented wizard but not even
close to the level of the dark
lord from there voldemort began making
his way toward lily and baby harry
still dead set on his goal of killing
the boy voldemort was over the threshold
as james came sprinting down the hall
it was easy too easy he had not even
picked up his wand
lily take harry and go it's him go
run i'll hold him off hold him off
without a wand in his hand
he laughed before casting the curse
avada kadavra
though voldemort did not give james the
same luxury when he approached lily he
gave her an opportunity
a chance to step aside a way to live he
explained that if she simply stepped
away
and let him have harry that he would
spare her life this was at the request
of severus snape
who loved lily and likely deeply
regretted relaying the prophecy to
voldemort
unsurprisingly however lily did not
allow voldemort to have her son
and refused this led to voldemort
murdering her with the killing curse
with both parents out of the way it was
time for baby harry
the boy who threatened his power to go
wasting no time
voldemort fired a killing curse at harry
but what happened next
changed the course of wizarding history
rather than harry dying
the killing curse rebounded back at
voldemort destroying him
for a time however tragically this date
not only marks the destruction of
voldemort
but the destruction of the potter family
as well without drilling down into it
too much
baby harry was protected from voldemort
because of lily's loving sacrifice
her sacrificial protection in harry
potter it's commonly expressed that love
trumps all other manners of powerful
magic and in this instance
that power was truly showcased in its
totality
stopping the dark lord in his tracks
your mother died to save you
if there is one thing voldemort cannot
understand it is love
he didn't realize that love as powerful
as your mother's for you leaves its own
mark
not a scar no visible sign to have been
loved so deeply
even though the person who loved us is
gone will give us some protection
forever however i've always wondered one
thing
why didn't james's loving sacrifice
protect lily
we can clearly see him sacrificing
himself lily
take harry and go it's him go run
i'll hold him off and he clearly loved
lily harry with all of his heart
so why didn't this same powerful love
help to protect the rest of his family
he knew he was going to die and he made
the ultimate sacrifice to protect them
where was the sacrificial protection it
turns out that rowling has actually been
asked this very question
in an interview this is one of my
burning questions since the third book
why did voldemort offer lily so many
chances to live
would he actually have let her live
why can't tell you but he did offer
you're absolutely right don't you want
to ask me why james's death didn't
protect lily and harry
there's your answer you've just answered
your own question because she could have
lived
and chose to die james was going to be
killed anyway
do you see what i mean i'm not saying
james wasn't ready to
he died trying to protect his family but
he was going to be murdered anyway
he had no he wasn't given a choice so he
rushed into it
in a kind of animal way i think there
are distinctions in courage
james was immensely brave but the
caliber of lily's bravery was
i think in this instance higher because
she could have saved herself
now any mother any normal mother would
have done what lily did
so in that sense her courage too was of
an animal quality
but she was given time to choose james
wasn't
it's like an intruder entering your
house isn't it you would instinctively
rush them
but if in cold blood you were told get
out of the way
you know what would you do i mean i
don't think any mother would stand aside
from their child
but does that answer it she did very
consciously lay down her life
she had a clear choice and james didn't
did he clearly die to try and protect
harry specifically given a clear choice
no it's a subtle distinction and there's
slightly more to it than that but that's
most of the answer
in essence rowling explains that the
difference between james's death and
lilies
is that voldemort always intended to
kill james and james was always meant to
die
voldemort never had any intention of
letting james live
but he was willing to let lilly live he
gave her multiple chances to step aside
and save herself
but she still wasn't willing to let him
have harry the fact that she could have
saved herself
but didn't showcases her extreme love
for harry
since james was always destined to die
it would have been impossible for him to
showcase the same level of sacrifice
even if he loved harry and lily just as
much as lily loved harry
and that's it for this video did you
guys ever wonder this
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
remember to the well organized mind
death
is but the next great adventure
[Music]
you